what's going on guys today we're going
to be breaking down the trailer for the
third hero academia movie
which is called world heroes mission
while this trailer was a short preview
that only lasted about 30 seconds
there are still many details we can
gather from what's been shown so far
including the fact that at least some of
it is set in america and doku is
literally wanted for mass murder
before we get into it be sure to hit
that sub button as i will be doing
weekly videos about my hero season 5
from next week
and of course drop a like if you like
the video okay so the first thing we
should talk about from world heroes
mission is the villain
and based on the info we have right now
i think we can guess what this guy wants
the trailer kicks off with the bad guy
taking a step forward and we can see
that he has red orbs on his feet which i
think is related to his quirk but i'll
get to that in a minute
during this preview the villain
questions if quirks are a blessing for
humanity
or if they're a power that can bring
destruction to the world with the
trailer later showing there is a world
crisis
as quirks are causing many disasters
across the globe i'm pretty sure this
picture here was actually from ground
zero from the all might versus all for
one fight but whether it is or not
the point is that these superhuman
powers are destroying society
therefore we can assume for now that
this villain is like overhaul and that
he potentially wants to eradicate works
in some way
to stop this global crisis you may then
be wondering how he's going to do that
and i think the answers can be found in
this part of the trailer as we see the
main villain is up here
and he has a cult of people that follow
him several of his minions seem to be
performing a ritual
and either this is like guardians of the
galaxy where they're creating a new life
form
or more likely whatever they're doing is
going to give the villain leader some
kind of power
up that will enable them to fulfill
their plans regarding what his quirk
might actually be
as i mentioned there were red orbs on
his feet during the opening shots but
later on we see there are orbs in his
actual head as well
in this dream sequence hawks's wings are
falling from the sky whilst the bad guy
stands on top of the dead students of
class 1a
so obviously whatever these brain orbs
do it must be very overpowered for
someone to even think
that you can beat all of class 1a not to
mention hawks as well
purely speculation here but given that
his goal is possibly to erase quirks
maybe his own power ties into that and
perhaps these orbs are like a
supercharged version of erasure
that allow him to disable all quirks
within a certain radius
if he had a base power like that then by
supercharging it with a drug or some
kind of ritual
perhaps he really could get rid of every
quirk in the world but like i said this
is just my speculation
on a separate note the villain seems to
be based in america as i'm pretty sure
this is the golden gate bridge in
california but someone in the comments
let me know if you think this is
somewhere else
the most bizarre moment of this entire
thing was a news reporter
stating that deku is wanted for mass
murder and i just didn't know what to
think of this to be honest like
clearly he's being set up here i doubt
deku is actually a mass murderer
but i just thought it was kind of funny
that people would even think that this
guy
is capable of doing that on the
broadcast itself the text was in english
so that shows us that deku's killing
spree is happening in america
and did not occur before he left japan
we'll have to wait and see how he was
set up
but i am curious why it's only midoriya
who's a wanted person
because it's not like he's working alone
here like if he's in america then he's
definitely with at least you know
shoutout back ago and possibly endeavor
as well
so yeah we'll have to see why it's only
deku's being framed
the trailer begins to end with this cool
sort of two planes heading towards a
city
and one of those planes is the three
musketeers while in the other is most
likely the endeavor agency
being in separate planes indicates they
have different missions so maybe the
main tree will have to defeat the main
villain
whilst the endeavor agency are trying to
stop something else from happening
instead
after all the movie poster tells us this
guy will meet the three musketeers
which heavily implies that they will be
the ones to face off against him
there was a separate moment where we
also saw hawks and tokyo army flying
across the golden gate bridge so i guess
the villain hideout is located quite
close to this landmark
in the background we see three planes
this time so either the third plane is
simply out of shot here
or the people on that plane have a
different mission away from the city
the subtitles on screen say there is a
crisis threatening the existence of the
world
and that these heroes only have two
hours to stop it though i wonder if
those two hours are referring to the
movie's runtime
or if the heroes themselves literally
have two in-universe hours to stop
whatever's happening
whatever the situation might be this
trailer for world heroes mission has
definitely got me interested
and for those of you that don't know it
will be released in japan on the 6th of
august 2021
as of making this video there are no
international release dates but i'm sure
in due time you know in a few months
we'll find out when exactly it's coming
to the rest of the world
let me know down below what you guys
thought of the trailer and also if you
have any idea of what this video's quirk
might be then i would like to hear it
because i'm pretty sure my idea is
probably going to be wrong but you know
i liked it but
yeah i i'm not sure i'm not 100 sure yet
thanks for watching as always and until
the next one
peace out